kirsten the driver charged with killing
five bicyclists near searchlight last
month
will stay locked up for now without bail
jordan barson
had his first court appearance this
morning following his extradition from
arizona
hector mejia has the latest on the dui
case
jordan barson learned about the charges
filed against him directly from a judge
has two previously scheduled court
hearings were delayed
because he was in quarantine the 45 year
old has been charged with 14
felony counts including dui resulting in
death
and reckless driving barson is accused
of killing
five bicyclists on december 10th on u.s
95 near searchlight
the group was riding from las vegas to
nipton according to investigators
methamphetamine was found in his system
barson's defense argued for bail to be
set at 20
thousand dollars judge susan bockham
said no way
she said barson is not only a danger to
the community but a flight risk as well
she pointed out that if he is found
guilty he faces over a hundred years in
prison
if he's given the maximum sentence i
don't think that there's any of that
money
that can satisfy the safety of the
community after
the horrendous decision that we've said
we see that he may drive nine times over
the
legal limit the i-team learned that
barson is now declared an imminent
hazard to public safety
federal investigators say barson and
road runner transport az
the company he worked for were not
carrying a log book as required by law
records also show the company is not
authorized to work as an interstate
carrier
barson's snake's court hearing is
scheduled for january the 21st
reporting outside the regional justice
center hector mejia
8 news now